now have you heard about what's
happening with drake and this hot sauce
condom situation are you familiar with
this yes have you read up on this nancy
have you read on the about the hot sauce
okay so for those of you that are not
aware uh our friend eric is pulling up
the story so apparently the story goes
like this i'll try to summarize this and
then we'll get into the conversation so
drake and this instagram model right
which is like i'm using air quotes
galore instagram model so they're dm'ing
like people do they're dming and they
decide to link up so i think they go out
to a club they're doing their thing and
then he's obviously like ah let's go
back to the hotel room because after the
parties they have to party and after the
party the hotel lobby
so they they go back
they smoke a little something
you know they roll something up and they
agree
to have sex i'm putting that the
agreement in there because it was
consensual there's not any charges
towards drake in that fashion it was
consensual sexual intercourse remember
when that used to happen consensual
stuff yeah yeah okay
so allegedly yeah
usually that's your thing
by the way allegedly is never a good
word to have it's never like allegedly
he donated right there on the chart but
it's never like allegedly he donates his
time to the homeless
allegedly [ __ ] put hot sauce in
a condom right
so
they have sex he uses a condom he
practices safe sex literally and then he
goes to the bathroom just to dispose of
it dispose of the condom he throws it in
the trash bin right
so and here is where things get a little
juicy juice of juicy juicy all right so
according to the report allegedly
um the girl then goes to the bathroom
she grabs the used condom out of the
trash and she tries to basically
stick it up you know her situation and
tries to literally impregnate herself
with drake's sperm in the condom that
was in
the trash can okay cool but surprise
surprise ladies like it's freaking taco
tuesday over here
drake allegedly pours hot sauce like
freaking cholula king over here pours
poured hot sauce into the condom to kill
the sperm i've never heard of this move
before in my life so he does that
naturally the girl freaks out she
basically says that it was like like
pouring hot lava in her vagina and
basically now
her burning situation now is basically
calling drake out and she is
threatening to sue
drake
so that is the context of the story i
don't know this is probably the craziest
story i've maybe ever heard okay
so first question what the [ __ ] have you
ever heard a story like this either one
of you guys quite entertaining it's very
entertaining this is the attainment of
valuetainment right here so
is there any circumstance in your life
any dude out there that you would resort
to putting your hand in a trash can and
trying to insert a used condom so you
get knocked up by a
multi-multi-multi-multi-millionaire is
there anything this is even comprehend
as a lady
no okay one word answer no nancy the
first time you did something like that
what happened
it was actually what she said
it didn't work
no i i couldn't see myself doing that i
think i have too much anxiety to go
through with it it's like i'll be
fumbling all that stuff
okay all right so you're obviously not
gonna self-incriminate you know clearly
classy ladies we wouldn't have them on
however
do you have any girlfriends that you
think would do something like this jenny
i know you're from miami
oh don't put some ma'am in the
background
you're gonna go crazy yeah we're gonna
get there any girls in general
from your time on the road dancing
having fun that you could see you know i
think we're gonna leslie will do
something like that is there anyone that
would do something listen i've seen
quite a few interesting things so yes i
have you do know some ladies that would
who would potentially do that like i'm
not going to ask you to name names but
you're thinking of a few right now i
mean miami is kind of yes so they would
sleep with a celebrity they would think
all right let me go investigate that
trash karen okay but there's just so
many problems with the story number one
i don't know if it's really not but
let's say let's claim it is real yeah
and we want some entertainment allegedly
right
number one
scientifically from my understanding
what i've been taught okay is when the
sperm hits oxygen it dies so the sperm
cannot live outside
of my vagina okay okay trust the science
that's true
so therefore i don't know why he didn't
flush the condom down the toilet dude
this is my
hot sauce a trash can you're busting out
burritos like dude just throw it in the
garage
i don't think because i'm not going to
lie when the story came out i literally
my first thing i googled was can hot
sauce kill sperm that was my first thing
and that's on your search history yeah
everything was a drake drake drake drake
director drake i said wow this is a
great marketing tactic yes however does
he have an album coming out no he
already has which is what i said i said
his pr guy needs to come out and be like
all right we need to come come out with
a record breaking news drake just signed
a sponsorship with cholula hot sauce
you talk about money that's how you flip
the story and that's how you generate
boom many dollars from an unfortunate
situation like this okay but i don't
think that he put hot sauce to kill the
sperm i think he put it to see
who he's messing with
which i don't know why people at that
level are still playing games like that
like be with loyal women that at least
you know i don't think he's looking to
spend his life with this girl i think he
was just spending the night i know but
i'm saying like have your fun but be
with women who respect and understand
your lifestyle versus just trying to
like like some guys they think with the
wrong head and just get caught up in the
wrong situations nancy well i mean
that's obviously his test then because i
imagine if he's like [ __ ] a million
hot girls then eventually he's going to
want to recycle one of them so
they have to like go through the test of
you got to go through the hot sauce test
okay that's exactly what he did okay so
he's like which one of these girls is
going to start screaming ranting and
raving in the bathroom you have failed
this test you have to process your name
off the crust yeah
sherry
yeah okay so uh do you have anybody that
comes to mind that you would even you
know she's thinking of a few names is
there anybody in your life that you
think yeah that [ __ ] will do something
like this anyone you know
uh
probably not okay you roll with a classy
crew you're from dallas originally yeah
dallas you're a humble crowd we're
basically calling out miami right now
okay
now i'm getting offended
i just feel like a lot of miami girls
have a bad rep i'm not going to lie yeah
all right and i take loki offenses
though understood but not i just want to
make a statement that not all miami
girls are like this clearly not you're
absolutely right absolutely you just
want to clear the air there's ninety
percent no just kidding
oh my god i'm just kidding i'm from
miami i know classy girls but also
you know
it is a party culture you know it is
it's like but
by the way this didn't happen in miami i
think this happened in toronto i want to
say it could be wrong but it didn't
happen in miami so where's the girl from
nobody knows i don't know but we can
find out who she is on instagram if you
eric why don't you do some you know some
reconnaissance work what's going on
right there okay so
is there any amount of money
or any do there she is oh but people
know oh you know her no i just didn't
know that people like knew who she was
like i thought her name was she's
verified her name is melissa ford is
that her i like how it starts off as
like unknown ig model and then that's
what i'm saying that's why i didn't know
what she was up eric scroll up just a
little bit
okay p.s if drake doesn't seize this
moment to launch or license his own
branded hot sauce jenny then canadians
are even dumber than i thought boom
jenny hit the nail on the head so this
happened in canada
i'll even give you a name for a 20
revenue show the drizzy sizzy that's
okay pps last i heard was drake was
slamming video vixen hall of famer
melissa ford
not saying it was her by any means just
wanted to post some pics so they're not
even saying that's her so allegedly we
don't know who the name is okay they
have a list of women a list of women
that it could
be
so okay let's play a game let's play a
game feel free to say hell no
but for
any amount of money
any amount of money
or for any dude dream dude channing
tatum danny devito whoever your dream
dude is
is there any amount of money or any
person you would actually
consider doing something like this
no too many morals for that too many
morals so if i'm like listen jenny
10 billion dollars
all you got to do so there's no amount
of money
you cannot be bought no and i'm going to
tell you this one story i was on a
beautiful
boat that was like a mini cruise ship to
be honest there was a boat on the boat
so you know how big the boat is at this
is the boat on the boat yeah okay so
you're not making the borders talking to
a billionaire yep
and i said can i ask you a question i'm
a question girl asked many many
questions he said yes of course i said
are you happy and he looked me in the
eyes and he's like
i'm trying to be
trying to be this billionaire who never
has to work a day in his life if he
doesn't want to
to to me i just
there's too many more there's too many
values and a lot of that has been lost
in today's society
and i pride myself in having
that and
if i go i'm not going to take my money
with me but i'm going to take my
integrity with me
this is what we call around here having
values and principles yes and you got
them girl respect to you point jenny so
nancy when you get that 10 billion
dollars i think i would just [ __ ] it up
so fast what's the amount what is there
an amount is there a number out there
that you're like
[ __ ] it copy the check i'm with you is
there anything
you know this is a hypothetical you're
not reaching the trash cans but is there
anything or any amount of money or any
person you're like [ __ ] it i'm in
anything i don't think i can do it i
feel like i'll just i wouldn't want like
the mental commitment to like anything
that's not mine okay
respect to you that's the values and
principles of being in a great
organization like valuetainment let me
give you guys a little perspective
for 10 billion
dre i will go in that trash can i will
throw hot sauce on any single body part
drake and his whole squad can run a tag
team i'm just
i'm just saying
i get it
go away i'm just saying
as much as i respect your girls
there is an amount of money that's like
that's life-changing but and you know
like so for instance
okay no there's some dead air right
there okay clearly i can't get pregnant
for those of you guys you know whatever
but
did you know that drake i'm not saying
it's a hot sauce situation but you know
that he impregnated a woman and she has
his kid yes his son i believe his name
adonis doesn't even look like him by the
way like a blonde looking kid
um she's a multi-millionaire now because
he's making
um child support payments he's taking
care of the kid
um
just putting that out there i mean
there's no amount of money there's no
amount of money i get it i get i'm just
saying like her life changed forever
just by having jake's kid
everybody's talking about the parents
but what about the kid did the kid even
ask to be born no how are they parenting
him
like
kids that are brought up in broken homes
end up broken and broken people hurt
people her people hurt people
you get me so people hurt people wow i
feel like i'm in a therapy session right
you are i'm not
latino living limitless dropping dimes
already always make sure you pick them
up make sure you pick them up
okay nancy before we move on any any
things that come to mind with
this drake situation is
drake at fault here is drake the bad guy
dude this is the story
drake is not the bad guy
is she the bad guy
i'm sure she sold that story to tmz and
got a good chunk of change for that
story oh so this is this is this is
something you're talking about wouldn't
she be the one who released the story
i don't know exactly that's a good point
nancy marketing executive suiting for
damages right because she got like hot
sauce
exactly
like why would you tell anybody that
story out of that's what i'm saying
does this story make you like drake more
or less or it's not it's a non-factor if
it's more if it's real it makes me think
that he's a smart man oh so you like him
more a little bit
the hot sauce
i need
if it's real i think it's a funny story
like i don't think he's at fault like
okay so drake's not the bad guy anyway
guys coming in 2022 we got the drizzy
sizzy hot sauce sponsored by chalula and
you can get that at all valuetainment
superstores across the country all right
drake uh he was the artist of the decade
and now something tells me he's gonna be
the businessman of the decade with his
hot sauce so respect to you drake and i
actually think that the girl um she's
trying to catfish drake you know
whatever catfishing is in this capacity
and
she got caught she got got she got
punked she got hot sauce that's like a
new move we're gonna see i feel like
guys are gonna use this move i'm sure a
lot of guys are gonna do this you got
sauce yeah
drinking you're welcome to the sauce to
bring your hot sauce anytime you'd like
you